today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza 1811 Pico Boulevard on
the way to the beach in Los Angeles gray
block get that hitter today's episode is
brought to you by skills share skills
share do you have skills do you not have
any skills if you want to do something
are you able to do it and you just don't
know how are you just standing around
with an axe and a tree and not knowing
what to do well learn a skill skill
share is an online learning community
for creators with more than 25,000
classes and design business and more
you'll discover countless ways to fuel
your curiosity creativity and career
take classes in social media marketing
creative writing mobile photography even
illustration illustration playoffs
whether you're looking to discover a new
passion start a side hustle or gain new
professional skills Skillshare is there
to keep you learning join the millions
of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for our listeners you can get two
months of Skillshare for free that's
right skill share is offering this past
weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 25,000 classes
for free to sign up go to Skillshare
comm slash Theo von again go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo von to start
your two months free now that's
Skillshare comm slash Theo von a lot of
times think think people think about
Ridge Walla tree and say how to do
wallets well let me guess that you don't
know something else and that's that
Ridge does knives if you're if you don't
if you don't have a wallet get a wallet
but if you don't have a knife get a
knife that Ridge piece I keep it in my
car in case somebody come at me you want
to wash a can I wash your windows no you
can wash your own life out of your shirt
because I'm a pokey bucko
visit Ridge wallet dot-com slash hitter
a chai tter
and use code hitter at checkout for 10%
that's code hitter a chai tter for 10%
off at Ridge wallet dot-com
slash hitter today's guest has a new
Netflix special out called the Tennessee
kid I don't see him very often but I'm
about to see him right now
and this young buckaroo has helped us is
helping or will help us today with
another round of this past weekend's
state Wars March Madness I want to thank
everyone who sent in so many amazing
video submissions it's been absolutely
awesome and intriguing we'll have a
little bit of interview then we'll get
into into the state Wars ladies and
gentlemen mr. Nate bargatze what's going
on man welcome to town thanks buddy your
specialist came out off yeah that's
awesome so it's fun you know how
exciting is uh
it's great you know I go years I mean
your winters come out like thinking
about four years ago it's great
everything is so longer you like 15
years ago all right
I just watched it I just downloaded it
on a flight oh really
yeah yeah didn't care for it yeah
totally totally it was great no no it
was great
I I just downloaded I like to download
some like occasion like in a you know
you had a nice flight in breeze in see
comedy I think it's good yeah randomly
be checking out and seeing what's going
on yeah see what's going on so does it
get you excited like you know like when
you got to build a new act and all this
Senators you need to get like motivated
and like watch some other specials to
like just I don't know getting like
pumped about its but yeah that's like
the exciting process did you have some
fear like what were some of the fears
you had about like you get fear that
like you wouldn't be able to make new
material like did you have any of that
I'm not right now I have it like I don't
I don't think however I never think I
could come up with any jokes ever again
any like I did a Comedy Central special
forever ago and that was like Robin you
know where when you're done you're just
like I'll never be as funny as like that
and I won't be able to come
but anything else I don't see how I
would come up with anything else out
loud I don't have a process to come up
with anything like does not you don't
have like a thing that you're like I do
this I go write this down and then a you
know it's all gonna happen yeah
you can't like it's hard to are it's
hard for me to generate to force to
generate like new stuff I mean I try to
like you know you try to like just be
good about making your mind open I've
learned it's not your process me your
process is your process yeah yeah and
your process is what a lazy nothing I
don't write it's a it just comes more on
stage and you hunt stage I'll put it
like a little note in my phone of an
idea and I try not to write because that
are ready to like word-for-word I've
tried it some but I think you if you do
that yet for me I will not sound as
conversational and so if like I'd like
to just do you have any in your phone
right now yeah yeah yeah I might have
sent it you want to say let's see what
her bad woman do have full ideas don't
use the racial slur ones you know what
I'm saying brother to go for my other so
Nexus I'm gonna different route my next
special just I have one warm juice on a
plane yeah I knew what that means that
was one and that like you just put that
and then you'd figure it out from there
yeah yeah I had I got I bought a
reversible jacket about two of them cuz
I didn't know they were reversible
goddang and then you got both sides of
the same coin I was saying and here's
the trick I'm saying here's the truth of
that is I didn't buy it but I was buying
it and I happened to the last minute
realize it she bought it yeah and so I'm
just saying but it was the all the the
feelings of buying this check were there
and it's a black one and then I saw went
to the store and I saw a blue one I was
like well I like this jacket yeah
so I'll get a blue one too and I'm like
I'm literally grabbing it and uh and I
just happen to check sorry I happen to
see the inside of it and realized it was
reversible so it has four pockets
because it has two on the outside and
two on the inside Wow
pretty cool yeah but I just thought that
was like if you think you lost your keys
and you did but you've checked all four
pockets
oh the outside inside dude I hate that
man you ever check all your pockets and
after you lost something and then you
[ __ ] check them again bro like you
yes like you're like hold on I didn't
really dig in I'm like seven inches deep
yeah you're like I don't know do it like
a back but like you get it back and
you're just checking you're like it has
to be here somewhere
yeah and you just dig unbeliev take you
shake it like that school everything
else yeah do you change your backpack
out like a lot do you like this backpack
for seven years I got this to me
backpack and it's kind of a fancy
company and I don't want to pack one
time yeah but I bought it seven years
ago I don't know if I'll change I've
seen some newer ones that I kind of like
but it just keeps serving me well yeah I
love travel stuff oh yeah I can walk
into a good a to mean just like walk
around like what are you guys what's
what's happening now right like what's
happening in here well I know yeah yeah
and was a new drop the new thing I heard
offsets doing a [ __ ] brand design
with you I don't even know they think
you know more than yeah yeah yeah you
didn't hear about the [ __ ] wailings
bag that's coming out it's a pretty big
bag yeah I like travel I like like go I
love like luggage like it's just
whatever the easiest you know I'd shower
check a bag I'm not a [ __ ] bag Oh No
yeah a lot of people don't they don't
they're you know killers dude that's who
does yeah I know it's a it's but it's a
lot of people they they don't want to
wait they're pretty good about getting
your bags out there now some airports
let's be honest yeah we can talk about
the south because that's a place where
sometimes they're not New Orleans you
could wait a weekend after a bag they
just don't even one guy brought it one
time they brought in no joke I was like
four days later dude was no joke I swear
to God that we denied it had on one of
the [ __ ] shirts in my bag yeah he
just took it out in war yeah he's a
tough guy yeah and I couldn't he took it
for a run I don't want to go to bat with
him about it yes happy to have the rest
of my stuff yeah but some airports in
New Orleans nothing at any wore this
shirt it takes 20 minutes yeah
he forgot anymore I think he got a
little cooked up and [ __ ] forgot he
wore yeah and then just has it on and is
like is your bag at school and you just
gotta go a guy you know like yeah cuz
it'll be con conversation like you have
to hey that's my shirt yeah I'm not
getting involved in that yes even though
I would love to get love to see get
involved like just to see what he's
gonna say like cuz it's a guide like
that that could be let you say it and
he's like yeah yeah how do you know
we're gonna do where we gonna go from
here where do you want to go from either
yeah like how far do you want to take
this and then you just have to be like
alright I mean I guess this is as far as
we take it yeah you know unless you want
to just go at it I would love to live
like that guy I would love that I'm
jealous of that guy that you could put
on someone's shirt out of the luggage
that's not yours deliver it and and like
I mean he's routing that you say yeah
that point he's bi like please say
something yeah but I'm going to do the
most obvious thing you know this is your
shirt I hope it's like a real shirt
that's like it's not like and you know
just like a polo that you're like you
could argue right it's something that's
like oh yes right up you it was like
Vaughn family reunion yeah yeah family
and they just any and I mean there's
only a couple you want everybody sit on
the other side of the table from my
mother far away from her yeah and they
it's like the Last Supper but like like
they're on the out you just see the
backs like you just see your mom's face
and you rest your family back yet any
supper yeah no but you're right he shows
up and he probably got off the car
thinking man I hope this [ __ ]
oh I would love it he just would love it
he would love it it'd be nothing more I
love I love confrontation I don't like
doing it yeah but I love the I you know
you lived through the idea of it like if
I see some of being confrontational it's
like there's nothing better
Nick Thune comedians very
confrontational is he he yeah he only
has a bill to support it I don't feel
like he know he doesn't that but like I
think it's all just the people or don't
expected so if you are like they don't
know how to like oh it's like react to
it because you're I mean you're calling
someone out in me
like why did you do that yeah yeah yeah
because he kind of how I feel like he
gives off a little mist all - yeah
that's true he kinda is that male kind
of like Portland male ballerina but
[ __ ] me yeah has some violence in his
legs but he's doing yeah he's very very
talented I don't mean that like no yeah
I'm just trying to think of his
aggression style
well it's he's cool you know I think you
want to be like if you see him you'd be
like I want that guy to like me he is
like the most interesting man in the
world kind of yeah that energy yeah yeah
I think you could like beat him like
you'd be worried about he's doing shows
in Mexico right now really yeah I don't
know like I'm like I don't know I don't
know he speak Spanish you must know no
no I don't not that I know of
yeah I think he would bring that up if
he did but he's in Mexico yeah I don't
know that's awesome not a goal one day I
want to go do tour tour in the in
Central America in South America you can
go down you have a pretty big fan base
in there I don't know I think I could
probably you know I think um I think I
think I would like it my father's from
Nicaragua my father grew up in Nicaragua
Oh
and so he was here when he was 12 but so
but I would like to be able to go and be
a part of that just universe and
entertained to see what it's like you
know and just to see I did a show in I
say this on stage to talk about like I
just showing Tambor like a corporate gig
and the guy booked me on it and he it
was like you know you get some of these
you get booked for stuff and it's like
through the proper channels so it's like
vetted and and then that your your if
you do a corporate you're performing for
someone but they hired someone that
knows how to book a comedian right and
this guy just kind of was like a fan and
booked he went through the channels
right but he didn't talk to anybody like
on how to even set stuff up oh yeah and
is like 600 people and I went up bombed
for one hour straight and then
afterwards he tells me that none of them
speak English hot and so he never he
never mentioned that until like I like
in an email later like he was like all
right I got done he's like that's good
and I was like I don't even know I was
like you're out of your mind if you
thought that was good he was given away
iPads
and gave away two cars like he's a good
yeah it's a it's a it's all in his heart
is in the right place yeah and the guy
that drove me to the show
it sounds like an the Ellen Keller
DeGeneres Show that's what it sounds it
sounds like people that can't hear but
they're giving away a lot of yes yes
great yeah yeah yeah it's uh they
thought of that can you crazy
sorry now that was good Elliott I don't
know what that means anymore
yeah the Ellen Keller Helen Keller sorry
yeah sorry to just keep repeating mojo
no Helen Keller is a good it deserved
more than I gave it well she's the most
famous person that's impaired think of
someone impaired that's more famous than
Helen Keller staring one is Stevie
Wonder Stevie Wonder's doing good but
they do different two different things
telling right uh Helen Keller couldn't
hear so you wonder couldn't see yeah if
you can't hear you can't what else you
guys know Michael J Fox yeah but he does
you have it or not they said it's gonna
kill me five years ago and it hasn't
yeah
Steven sorry yeah alright yeah that's a
little weird not popping it to him we're
like not gonna be oh my god you'd be
like I don't know I mean ya know that's
amazing relate he keeps acting - yeah
they did the whole show he had a sitcom
like everybody's obviously very famous
yes Stephen Hawking was one too he
couldn't do anything except be like real
smart yeah he was in that movie - any
app had a a couple of different wives
didn't even leave his wife and he liked
his nurses - yeah I don't blame him ya
do - fine if I'm in a chair man I'm
gonna be in the chair for a long time I
think I would probably try to try at
least to probably [ __ ] whoever comes
near me because you you know yeah cuz
it's probably not you can never really
get charged for rape or something cuz
it's like yeah like no whatever I'm not
gonna like fall then you're not the
chair of Rob one month when I thought
absolutely like aggressive like but I'm
saying even if you were aggressive they
wouldn't be like just walk oh why didn't
you walk away like it's like at one
point is
it's gonna be the girl's fault yeah he
was he literally couldn't move so I
don't you know I'm saying like there's
no you could be aggressive yes there's
yeah what do you nuclear your throat
yeah yeah I mean yeah
how great like you personally have to be
through the roof yep yeah like yeah just
so tuned in to like where she's like
it's gonna happen but yeah I don't think
you would ever get you know I would
never do anything like that
you would never be addressing it no I'll
when doing thank that I mean I don't
think I would ever do anything like that
I would never like I mean I'll tell you
this if I was stuck on around with a
woman and she wasn't interested I'd
definitely be probably pissed off but I
wouldn't ever be like sure you'd have to
break it down I mean it has to be cuz
you have to talk about it every day
about you're not interested eventually
in I bet you'd be interested she has to
have a change of pace I mean just like
everyday just be like I think you should
play games dude like back off bringing
it up yeah and then bill I'm not go same
thing and then maybe when she does get
interested be like well I'm not
interested now and I would turn yeah and
then you're like I don't wanna it'd be
along here we got that boat comes and
some of the Joe hook up a bunch you like
you know we did it you think we would
but we didn't at all bro how sad though
would that be a guy comes to pick you up
it's you and her you've been on island
for a year right he's just like eyes on
the boat he's like he gives he's like
happy for you like you guys are ready
some water some giving you a snicker you
know hits everybody back up to [ __ ]
par you know medically yeah and then
while she's kind of like he's kind of
facing you he's probably he's back side
behind her like and you're like no no
you know we just didn't just we couldn't
really line it up she was kind of busy
for a little bit and and then she me
choose you on the news when I'd be great
and then it all then you go to prison
then you go back to they go back back
that's where they really instead of
prison well what did they send you back
to the island instead of prison like
they just figured like let's try that
yeah oh the scene of the crime now yeah
yeah yet to go in there that wasn't a
good they wouldn't do that it wasn't as
how Australia started speaking of which
I'll be in Australia
where are you playing at where you tell
me what your shows are like now man so
people have started to probably more
people to come out yeah see you yeah
yeah but you know that now right like
yeah I mean it's happened to you too
right now right yeah it's definitely
been it's been busier yeah yeah it's
crazy yeah uh yes exciting it's fun you
go out and they know you and like how
you have to act I think you have to act
differently like you have to you know
there's a different we're used to
walking out on stage and nobody knows
this right so you gotta you trying to
win them over so that's like a vibe and
ring and now when you walk out the
applause is bigger they're more excited
just out just because you walk on stage
yeah and so now you have to like make
sure that it's up to poor for them like
you don't want to just bomb you know and
they're like oh dude I was like so
excited yeah do you think there's a way
this is this interests me because it
makes me makes me think about this yeah
like I wonder if in my mind I can just
make sure I focus on going back going
and staying in the space where I gotta
win these people over yes that you know
Seinfeld said though if he could go back
to one thing he would want the filling
is when they don't know you that's the
filling he would want to go back to
because there's no more rewarding
feeling than people being like I don't
know if this is even gonna be funny and
then you being really funny yeah and
like in you winning them over there's
that's the greatest thing ever like you
know so that's like such a that's what
we that's our whole beginning of your
career is that and then now your career
is now people do know you're they and
they see you and they they have an idea
of what to expect and those expectations
their expectation you got to keep on
because if you're not good then they're
gonna be disappointed yeah yeah it's
really interesting man it's so cool yet
so interesting it's interesting to think
about yet could I go back and then also
what was my mindset when I would go on
stage and people were not they didn't
know me and you had to like win them
over you just you were inside your eyes
them yeah yeah yeah you were you're
excited about like going on stage and
excited by your jokes I mean no like
when you have a good crowd and like you
can hear them laughing really hard like
out the gate and you're like I'm not
even like into my stuff yet yeah and
that's the greatest feeling on earth
like we're your that's the stuff I can
like make myself laugh on say cuz you're
just like
believe this is real like you're like
man we were so good yeah they think
you're going for a ride and you you you
know you're not even in the [ __ ]
truck yet yeah I always have a big fear
and I try to keep myself aware of it
like that the more you get known and the
more people there to see you I think
it's easier to slip and then not be as
good it not be as good as the reason
that they're there because they will
laugh I mean especially at the beginning
they laugh at stuff more than you know
just it's just easier to make them laugh
because they felt like that no me
chapelle ago said in place four or five
hours and it is not like bird shows up
and it's more comedy [ __ ] well work
minutes more celebrity yeah well he's
talking and he's just like that's what
he's that's what he did that's but I
thought his specials are great and every
and I didn't expect him to be great but
just because I knew he would go talk for
these hours right
and Sam company has to be tight it needs
to be you gotta get the fat out of all
this stuff and make the jokes very funny
and I thought his specials they did that
now I was actually very surprised
because I thought they were gonna be
this really long thing you know cuz
you're like where are you getting this
stuff tight like I don't write all I see
you is going on for two to four hours so
where are you at sometimes when he goes
on oh yeah but nowhere I remember in New
York when I first started he would come
and it was he wasn't doing that hours he
was doing Chappelle's Show and he might
do an hour oh yeah but he would go on
say just he likes being on stage it's
yeah I just really like he really loves
that that's a good point yeah he really
must love being on stage he likes
talking to people like ask him stuff and
just you know it's do you think so I
sometimes I think that comedy like it's
gotten it got too tight and now it's
loosening up and you want to see the
more like entertainment on stage you
want to like like writers like sometimes
like I feel like for a while it just got
like right like they just kept pushing
writers to like the champion of the
industry you know yeah and now I feel
like it's kind of taking a little bit of
a swing where it's more like people want
to I don't know they want to see the fat
on stuff more it seems like they want
things to seem more realistic maybe it's
just different yeah people do I get it
but people are different what do I have
any [ __ ] clue of people like hi they
do get
I think some comics like get like that I
mean like you know when louis c.k like
first blew up and he was like talking
about his kids like that he hey you know
this kids with jerks he hated his kids
or hated him yeah and uh that was like
something that's really resonated with
uh yeah and it changed but it changed
commie like a lot of comics like after
that and include myself is everything
became a little more personal everything
you talk about your life more
it wasn't you're just doing these jokes
that are like could be yours or not
yours so now it's like you're trying to
do jokes that only you can tell like you
have a voice for you that you can do you
know one can do you write write write
and like that's how it's like that it's
gotten more like that and like it that's
uh and that's a good thing and people
are getting it more there's still very a
lot of bad comedy out there there's a
lot of people that i don't think their
goal is to like murder onstage or like i
you know i started in york in these
clubs and it was all about murdering
like that's that's what it's all about
just murder be funny and like all this
and now it can be a little bit more
dragged out and you know more
interesting sometimes then funny and i
but i'm not a fan of that i think it's
funny like that's the that's the point
of what you're supposed to do up there
be funny if you can be both and be both
you know that is a yeah actually some
i'll actually kind of refined some
opposition even after you hearing you
they're like yeah i don't think it's
that yeah that entertainers but yeah i
think people want to get to know the
person more they want yeah something
that they can connect to a little bit
more and they like to laugh at you or
with you that's all I always looked at
it it's like I want you to laugh at me
because you can't believe I did it
or I'm doing something that you've done
and then you can laugh with me because
you've done it but I'm saying it about
me instead of like saying like I mean
I'm for me like I've never liked to like
point at the audience be like you're
this loser like I'll be the loser oh
yeah and I hope you come along like I
hope you can lo we're all [ __ ] yeah
welcome to the [ __ ] ship dude yeah you
know yeah we're halfway to Hades bro all
aboard yeah are there topics you won't
talk about that you want to talk about
sometimes uh I don't know I gotta really
get into like political stuff like yeah
I'm getting upload yeah I don't
I don't think anyway yeah not really
yeah I don't think yeah I don't think if
I do it I try to do it in a way that
it's like can ride both sides of it
I have no like I don't like really care
to be offensive like I don't have no
vulgarity you're not vulgar I'm not no
but they but I don't care to be a fit
I'm not trying to offend anybody I don't
want like push like I don't worry buddy
you're not gonna learn something from my
show like I don't care if you learn
something from my show I don't you don't
need to like I there's plenty of comedy
I we can I can whatever you're into I
can tell you who to go watch yeah if you
want this I don't we can't all be doing
the same thing the point of it is that
we're all doing very different things
and you should just be enjoy that you're
going to see you will be different than
seeing me to seeing whoever else that
burr to Chappelle you know you're
getting different things so if you're
into something just go watch the person
that does the thing that you like
yeah then if you're not into it then
don't go you know I don't like the idea
of like this you know you're supposed to
look like a voice it's like you should
use your platform to add a joke that was
somewhat argue please say Aye my special
about global warming you're saying how I
don't know I don't know what it is yeah
you know like I don't want to benefit if
you live in the [ __ ] north where you
about to get a beach and a couple you
right yeah but that you've been in
Alaska for [ __ ] 30 years and finally
your inbox remember like good you know
it kind of everybody kind of deserves
their turn with the beach I feel like a
little in there and Alaska's getting a
nod there and thrown their way oh that
yeah they called it they had a polar
bear the other day you know they caught
him with a couple of limes in his pocket
so you know they're getting crazy
polar bears are getting cooler yeah cuz
they're very aggressive yeah yeah
they're out yeah tow and then the cold
so much so now that they're aggressive
dude you're in the [ __ ] cold or they
don't know if somebody was like hey dude
you know my [ __ ] down here I think I
don't do bears ever just like they're
like woo like you never have back that
feeling of just you know cuz they don't
ever feel like they're cold they laying
in snow and is it ever just like oh like
they get in the water and you're like
who like there's you don't ever they
don't have that emotion like you never
see it so maybe it's in there but we
just don't
yeah theater I mean yeah why are they
not
yeah like you never see a bear that's
kind of rode a fire who is a little like
ice cold today you know just something
like you want to give them like warmth
like you go to the zoo and they have it
like real cold and you're like well how
do you not know what if they want it
well the zoo is a [ __ ] trap house
dude I mean let's be honest you can
smoke cigarettes they're animal caged up
it's almost like it's like the side
street in Amsterdam or the red-light
district you know it's like the orange
light district where they got the older
ladies if you go to red-light district
during the daytime in Amsterdam it's
older women
oh so it's more of those day times I
just work it late yeah anymore like
they're just like I just can't do this
yeah I can do those hours yeah no I'm
saying I'll [ __ ] I've get a bunch you
know yeah yeah those kind of lady
yeah and so you go there and you're
milling around and it's all these old
you know much easier to talk to nine
heads are gone if you suggested kids are
yeah they've been moved out like yeah
they stop for a little bit they're back
yeah I think they came back they always
I always stayed in touch just in case I
wanted to come back they like if you go
work at a restaurant again like after so
many years but yeah dude that's the
craziest of the Bob when you go back to
the restaurant and it's never the same
and you always think oh when I leave
this restaurant this place is gonna
[ __ ] go to the truth is oh you're
just a busboy
I can just wasted all the women all the
time dude I used to get two pockets full
of [ __ ] bread pudding and go sit on
the toilet and eat him while I was in
there with my bare hands row hahaha
good work yeah and yeah you would like
and I think I was probably one of the
better yeah some guy got busted by an
illegal shrimp over there and they
[ __ ] came in and cuffs one I didn't
took him out man he was buying it for
the restaurant yeah he was minding for
the restaurant he's buying it like
through an unmonitored channel yeah
basically like oh here's a guy with a
[ __ ] bucket over here where the here
these are usda-approved or whatever and
then he would just sell them and like
anybody like you get the bootleg how do
you eat that I like you know that's see
that's the ridge about the
confrontational guy like a guy wearing
his shirt is a guy like that a guy that
can you gotta be open we're to meet to
someone that's like do you want some
yeah you want what kind of shrimp do you
want yeah the Guv
shrimp or do you want to come to the
back of my car and yeah you want to say
that in the aquarium it is and then the
guy guys and gives it to people and
would never be like yeah like it you
know I just want people to not get sick
and stuff like that like he just has he
doesn't have that feeling to like Kate
like that that's an awesome guy
like you know I mean it's not good you
don't want to eat his shrimp but he's
brave I like that the guy things like
that that bravado yeah just yet that
ain't just kind of like yeah it's bonds
of shrimp yeah yeah that yeah they're I
don't know if anybody's in his life yeah
you ever meet a man chill out with all
little [ __ ] shellfish bro he don't
have anybody like that there's no one
he's like I've been friends with for
more than a few days yeah I guess like
just everybody that's in his life you
know this is my buddy and they in in
like you know you ever hear two people
talk like you're over here to like crazy
people talk and you want to just go like
do either one of you know what you said
like do you have if I had if I had to
pull you aside and put you in a room and
like could you break down what either
one it or would you just be like nada
nothing we don't know and they've never
known yeah they've never known well
people are a lot of people mean you know
a lot of people are straight criminals
and straight hos bro so one of the
reasons that we wanted you to be here
today
yeah and impart get she's from Nashville
or you live in Nashville I'm from there
you're from there yeah yeah and I was
actually just gonna go look at some land
out in leapers Fork actually oh yeah
nice area yeah I don't know if I could
afford it but I'm a good Rob past it
yeah it's a good we delivered I
delivered washers and dryers to one of
the Judds
oh really yeah a long time ago like and
we went in their house was it nice yeah
their house was big and they had a gym
in there and that was like you I've
never seen the juts as Wynonna Judd
maybe I don't know Ashley Judd as she
just like super hot
yes got a Patel's there busted looking
yes I guess his Wynonna Judd
we delivered a washer I delivered washer
to her damn and uh yeah and so and then
we I went to their house but that's
where like a lot of Libra Forks like
I think just to really have a place out
there like that's a lot of that stuff
like that yeah it's pretty far out but
it's very it's yeah it's a nice area
they have a little town like a little
town square and stuff like I went one
time cool yeah I went one time out there
and uh and I just really loved it it's
very cool I mean they have you know
Nashville's like insane there how hard
is it to get up there and do comedy and
practices or uh I don't do it much out
there like I'm doing a late night set
I'll run around to run that set but I I
basically do it on the road I mean I
figure it all out on the road like I
won't do some clubs this like I'm right
now I'm on doing like some theaters now
that we already had booked before we
knew when the specials would come out
all this so I have I'm roughly you have
like 40 new minutes and so I'm still
having to do some old stuff and then
I'll do some clubs this summer and and
then the fault or be like hopefully
completely turned over so you I could go
run around wherever I could go to Zanies
and like they have like they have stay
of nights like Tuesday nights enough for
me
I like I've I I think I write better
like on the road like doing a longer set
than I do
Oh interest uh 15 minutes I mean I was a
fifteen minute you know in New York
that's all you did but easily you write
better you used to use now just your
time on the road till take a little bit
of time during shows sometimes yeah you
got so much space because you're you
don't have to I can get you at any point
like you know like I have an hour up
here so you know when you're doing like
just 10-15 minutes I mean it's still
nice to do those spots and do them like
if I come here in New York I'll you know
go do some but but say if I'm in living
in Nashville is there an opportunity to
get up and perform sometimes in prank
every day every everywhere that they
have Nationals that got a little scene
now and like you know all the comics are
very young you know it's like 20 year
old people starting and they they have
some very cool rooms this play called
the East Room and there's some other
clubs opening up there Zanies is the
main cause that hitter yeah and then
they had a Dollar General you know yeah
we have a dog that one right across from
Zanies there's a Dollar General General
right across street oh yeah
so what we have here today I'm gonna let
you know whatever ah really I think you
could have moved maybe it's not me
I don't know I mean last time I was
Arabs it was closed but it only comes
late at night but I wanted to let you
know one of the reasons we were happy to
have you here is because we've been
doing the March Madness of states okay
so we've had Brian Collins come in yeah
and he's a he's kind of on the senior
circuit of comedy you may have seen him
and somebody is kind of older fella
older stuff yeah wasn't in black and
white but when they just sort of get
colored your ask some questions yeah
black white orange I mean they just
start having color like in film yeah and
then we had jo koy for the second round
and now we are cruising into where we at
NIT midway through the second round
right now we need wait through the
second round and we need your help so
it's a good time to watch the tournament
like it was second round like fun yeah
so some upsets oh yeah
and this is war this is if he stays
straight up a real-deal war yeah
silver war cuz state we could be headed
back to state run governments yeah sorry
American Civil War that I watched looked
up that wow it's cool so that's a sign
obviously that somebody knows something
we don't know yeah that Syria knows yeah
he just heard it's a silver war so this
is these are real estates that we'd be
fighting against each other some of them
already advanced another round where we
at Nick yeah we're through the midway
through the second round and we're gonna
start in the second round of the Midwest
okay
our first matchup is the two seed Ohio
versed Iowa okay and we have any videos
that came in for any on one of those
yeah here's Ohio Ohio is definitely
beating Iowa for one we invented
football one of the toughest sports ever
I looked up facts from Iowa the first
[ __ ] that I saw was that Iowa has the
most golf courses per capita nobody
playing golf can bust ass come on why
would he not put a shirt on for that
there's a number of people who and
there's a limited number of shirts
apparently in Ohio you know like they
don't I need the textile belt so what do
you think man Ohio Iowa let's start
right here with uh with what you even
think Nate what's the seedings is there
is there a reason they're seated or
y'all just put them in in each region
the top four seeds
advanced based on population they got by
okay and then the rest of that we tried
to have some good matchups oh there is a
reason the higher the seed more popular
so it's like is the whole state gonna
fight yeah Ohio split up that's the only
thing that's the big is it swing state
right like oh it's good so you got to
win that vote so you would have people
that are not gonna that could they could
be fighting with their own state which
could I would wildly take advantage of
they could now it's and none of this is
like really it's not it's not political
it's not political it's just straight up
the people it's the people but that oh
good people that the state has a lot of
/ ideas so like whatever their ideas
could be on is like I want eat a salad -
I want to eat a steak right those people
are gonna have to get along and I don't
in Iowa is like just straight up like
they do wrestlers I have a lot of
wrestlers out of a wrestling a lot of
big just like corn like you know just
like big dudes like I know how it does -
I have a lot of arms and legs in Iowa
arm and leg days big in Iowa Ohio has a
lot of Ohio I mean Ohio definitely is
the middle of America you know I mean
Ohio you have definitely like a lot of
football you have a lot of tradition you
have Columbus Cincinnati clear on Dayton
cam Canton I was that thing I'd work
golf courses that's huge those you got a
lot of golf but it's it's cold but I
mean I'm hung on the honestly like the
states being split as like it's just I
feel like it's two groups of people so
making them Iowa feels more unified than
Ohio would look I know how how is it a
two seed so it's and that's a seven seat
it's it's a big big if you go on a
population alone but Iowa I feel like
could be more organized they would be
all on the same page yeah they have a
lot of alcoholism - in Ohio I mean Akron
that's where a a program was started a
lot of drugs yeah a lot of straight-up
[ __ ] brain alaya
yeah a lot of symbol huge that would but
do some stuff like since I'm a ste dude
I saw a couple of sisters beat on there
was this do you know guy named Gary
minky
anyway some people [ __ ] beat this
dude up one time he he had two
milkshakes he was trying to I already
held one right advice yes I might press
it against his chest with his arm yeah
and the other one he had in his hand
because he was trying to film these uh
they had some like urban ladies out
there fighting in a parking lot right so
he got up real close with his camera
right and they were fighting so they all
three they were fighting each other
turned on him right and it McDonald did
closed so he had these two milkshakes
which it's hard to get if they spilled
McDonald's is not on board nothing in
their ice cream machine was broke its
we're down by two machines down so
you're down forever yeah and the only
way to get it to work is to be nice to
the [ __ ] at the way yeah yeah that's it
so then here's what happened bro these
these two uh these girls so he was
trying to run away but he had on these
shorts and the belt the short saw he was
taking about free tickets at comedy
clubs all the time this dude who's
famous where we drive around town and
give away free tickets to comedy clubs
in exchange for food at restaurants yeah
and he was this most haphazard an
amazing guy in his own right kind of
like this confederacy of dunces Ignatius
Reilly type of man you know but he's so
he's trying to run he had so many free
tickets in his pockets and they knows
the weight of those polled his shorts
down yeah so now he can't get away right
and he has these two milkshakes dude and
when you're apparently in his head you
don't [ __ ] ever let go to milk it
yeah yeah nice legs down you're not I
mean you're like this is it if you want
milkshakes you're not getting them yeah
these girls started that's a sure story
and there's some video of it was the
video that's like the video you see of
subsidy where you the camera eventually
hits the ground and you just hear it you
see the beginning of it yeah god I wish
we'd have seen that whole video and you
just goes this might be the most I've
ever laughed on here I'm feeling they
unified who were those they were all in
from Iowa they were oh they're idols so
those two girls were fighting each other
and then unified to fight this guy if I
think which is a strong point for Iowa
because they even if they're fighting
for the Battle of this state they seem
like well that was in Cincinnati oh that
was in Cincinnati no nevermind let's
hear from Iowa but you blew everything I
set up sorry yeah hey Theo Nate Nate I'm
a huge fan Theo I like your comedy too
but Nate you're great there's Gianni
from Rhode Island
I just wanted to weigh in on Iowa versus
Ohio I'm from Rhode Island so I have
nothing I've really no doggie window I
think Iowa would win because they have
corn and they could feed their soldiers
and Ohio just really has meth and also
Tom Arnold is from Iowa saying he's a
crazy bastard so he could basically you
know be the general of their army Tom
one will turn on the switch from owner
though yeah a little bit bizarre okay
first of all no more twinks obviously I
got a standing by the twink nation did
he have good points about it can you
recap that young fella said Tom Arnold
was basically his big smile Ashton
Kutcher's from Iowa yeah I mean you're
gonna have to have some upsets and so
like I just think like I would like is a
very like you're from Iowa they're proud
to be from Iowa and Ohio is uh II got a
little more transient I think it's a
little more like Cincinnati and Columbus
are wildly different cities Dayton is
wildly different they're all very like
they they could be their own states like
it feels like that's it's not like a
strong I mean they all like Ohio State
like I get that but I mean there's
people that like Cincinnati that are
diehard Cincinnati fans like in college
and they're not state everybody's an
outlaw gustavus state yeah but uh no but
yeah there's I don't know what I would
upset you're trying to give like look at
the dancing at up stats you got to pick
some you know yeah there's a good
there's no right way to do it
one thing Iowa has they've got to feel
the dreams so they can just have dead
people coming out of the corner yeah I
think that's uh just easing and that's
in Dyersville and actually pulled off
the interstate one time and spent some
time in their beautiful place so maybe
we'll start with this little twink and
I'll go Iowa I'll go upset on this one
the [ __ ] upset because that's a wild
you know
63% of the listener
said Ohio saddle tomboy Maurice Clarett
who I talked to this morning from
business and biceps but will take I will
take Gianni the twinks and she talked to
me yeah he was on the podcast mom oh
really yeah yeah he's great interview
yeah yeah yeah dude he was he was oh hi
he started down now that's the thing
hold on you're gonna have said let's to
get in some [ __ ] demographic have
some real brown dude come on
so let's see alright I want a real
mother
Maurice credits a great scenario you got
a guy that was about to get handed 100
million dollars and still went to prison
yeah like I mean like a guy that like
that's a straight-up dude that like and
in the the game the championship game
and when they play Miami he's the one
they fumbled and then went and got
ripped the back got the fumble back
which is a real and then now Sean
Taylor's dead - so yeah where was he at
Sean ohh Sean Taylor was that's why
ripped yeah that's how from yeah so he
killed him killed Sean Telo
that's pretty gangster brah I mean I
don't know it's a tough one it's a lot
of people we'll let everybody let's get
everybody's vote what do you think Nick
Gianni I like Iowa I think they're
scrappy corn-fed wrestlers okay I'm
gonna Iowa - yeah I mean I like it's an
upset man it's a big it's a big upset
it's all right you were hope you were
there to watch it you're gonna you know
you don't want to be out doing stuff you
wanted to see this happen yeah you don't
wanna be at the mall you don't be like
what happened you're like Ohio lost you
like what like who lost you know like
you would be I think it's a big okay
great all right oh wow Iowa it is Ohio
sweep next next matchup the three seed
Michigan first the six seed was kind of
gerrymandered into the Midwest Kentucky
yeah
have y'all done any upsets as Tennessee
we're we're out
yeah you guys lost in the first round
actually Virginia Virginia sorry uh yeah
they don't appreciate that okay so we
are on can you put away then in that
bracket right there all right Michigan
please bud and then we got Michigan and
Kentucky Michigan in Kentucky and here
is
we got a video that's why I'll tell you
what you don't want that upset you'd
love to see Michigan play Ohio yeah I
mean that's like that's but I can't have
that anymore
so we got Michigan and we gotta move
oh here's Jionni again this little twink
was that feel from Michigan representing
Kentucky don't stay into chance right so
first off Michigan two peninsulas the
only state with two peninsulas why does
that matter
because it's [ __ ] cool right so we
got three areas to Michigan really
insider guide here right we got like the
lower industrial part this is like Flint
and it's like Detroit all the rundown
[ __ ] you hear about
I mean flip they been drinking
radioactive lead water for years you
can't imagine what it does to those guys
be like down in Detroit man and that
place is burning it is always on fire
right um you can see the globe on a nice
night they can New York and Chicago you
can see the glow and there go
yeah there's Detroit you think about an
army of urban gentlemen carrying guns on
fire yeah you get northern Michigan
right a lot of deer hunters right some
desert shoot a neighbor's sometimes
they'll shoot another deer hunter they
don't really care too much they just
want to shoot some so they're
trigger-happy are them Kentuckians and
then the northern part of you pee they
called him the Yoopers right those guys
from Europe [ __ ] crazy
colds may have gone mad so Turkey don't
stand a chance
Gang Gang Gang brother dang Wow that's a
lot of information I like that yeah as
two peninsulas the only state that did I
don't know if I'm even positive what
Peninsula is but I like they have both
of them well yeah it's the three-sided
right yeah is Manhattan and Peninsula oh
it's an island they had an island like
Baja Mexico
yeah Rome well Florida like yeah Fort is
the biggest example of the penance yeah
Vince laughing
Wisconsin's got one btik Oh what else do
we have here Kentucky so there you got
Kentucky versus in Mitch that's a good
point Michigan what are the populations
of those can you figure that out for its
neck now Kentucky you've got horses man
you got out to you immediately they're
gonna be much more mobilized
Michigan you know they had the auto
industry but it left you know
everything's like crumbled there they
had success they had success but it so
then they'll have a chip on their
shoulder I mean they have a chip on the
shoulder but like Derek I just was in
Detroit and there it's a place that's
like popping back up now like you know
Michigan's like Detroit's like a city I
said city that like everybody kind of
roots for even if you have no agreed you
just everybody's like you want Detroit
to be good and like reach right that's
what they're saying yeah isn't it reach
right oh because they're doing it you're
trying to do it again no cuz they're
doing it again well that's not a good
thing for a fight though like to be like
we had to redo it right I'm you could
even get it together for the first fun
well we had them pop Kentucky's four and
a half million and Michigan is just shy
of ten one guys who sent in a video of
Michigan said that they have the car
plants which are shutting down but they
could easily oh that's a good one a time
of war switch those making tanks that's
a great point yeah you know we're eight
yes we regret we were just talking about
like you know we tell me that Iowa
Hawaii
oh hi oh and I was like worried about
but then it is like it's like I feel
like I was like would stick together be
very like like he's probably very
different but they're very they could
they could really like get together as a
group
and like really stand just like never
let up cuz they just are so good and
that's what could help but this is where
like Michigan's so many people like we
have a bigger population let's see what
Kentucky has going on here
Safiya just wanted to take couple things
about this upcoming match against [ __ ]
again
what are they water a lot of it layna
Lakes
I mean MSI Motor City you know it gets
kentucky's motor running is fatten and
[ __ ] me and that's what we do and
that's what we don't do Pacheco dragon
gang baby oh yeah I like that animal
call at the end then we got a really
short one for Kentucky as well okay
Kentucky well Wendy goes is the best ha
and then uh howling argument yeah was
that um Jeremy Pitts in that kidnapped
kid isn't him know
to Timothy pit-pat that's the video if
you guys gonna be like we need to know
that's a handsome you're a child whoever
sent that in and thank you brother
yeehaw do you too young fella I think
you're right I think the industrial side
alone having those plants having the
that in the genealogy of the people that
are there that they could start to
manufacture something they good together
I mean they like the amount think of the
speech that they gotta get you know the
speech that machines gonna give is like
we're we were taken once by just like we
didn't get it together I don't know you
know I'm not from there but like that
you know just like just they lost
Detroit there it all crumbled yeah in
like that speech in the locker room of
you know Oh like we're not gonna get
taken again right you could see we're
not gonna like yeah I could see them
like really getting everybody pumped and
excited like Michigan's like really they
need to be unified hi my parents are
from Kentucky they're from Louisville
yeah and Kentucky is like they're wild
in their own well they're fighting or
[ __ ] here's the thing now if you're
fighting and somebody wants to [ __ ]
you're gonna go [ __ ] so right there
you're not gonna be fighting at that
moment and I think that's when you get
beat for me it's a Michigan yeah word
Kentucky could be like it'd be like the
guy that's like two loud guy than just
gets laid out yeah I think those videos
like oh yeah like what do you think you
know we're eight talkers yeah oh yeah
the great talkers yeah it was close one
56 percent said Kentucky Wow damn dude
and I don't like University of Michigan
listeners they're all for - sorry
University of Michigan I love you I just
don't like I don't mind if they lose
sometimes that's right man alright next
matchup in the Midwest we got four
indiana versa
pesky 12 seed Minnesota and indeed
Minnesota versus Indiana
are you [ __ ] kidding me Minnesota
wins because I'm from Minnesota because
Minnesota is land of the
10,000 lakes because there are so many
good hip hop artists from Minnesota
point it's the four seasons you get the
summer the spring the winter those you
get it all it's beautiful all the time
Minnesota oh damn
Minnesota she she with that double
Minnesota right there bro not only
meaning that'll make me Jeff stayed a
little let's hear this young lady who's
this for Indiana a Theo
my name is Allison I'm from Valparaiso
Indiana to let you know that Minnesota
doesn't have a chance
Indiana would win hands down mainly
because Gary and Indianapolis Gary was
the murder capital of us in 1994 and
Gary and Indianapolis consistently still
make the list today killer we have just
our most plentiful killers in this state
and we just don't care
we have no respect for human life here
and that's just sad but good in this
competition sure that's right definitely
would win I don't think we'd win the
whole thing but at least enough to make
it something next around so that's all
oh yeah a little cutie bird there to
young lady from Valparaiso and I will
say everybody who sent in a video for
Indiana cited Gary it sounds like the
scariest place on earth oh yes dear
Chicago I think yes trying to kill a
couple times in the middle of the
Jackson from there from Gary I don't
know I like to state stuff that could
not be true just going it's a known fact
that Michael Jackson's story and a wild
place man
Wowz from there Michael Jackson is from
there no Gary ania yeah Francis from
Minnesota I know but like who like
Michael Jackson you know way to some
secrets yeah that's true uh but
continued a secret at somebody Indiana
is the real deal dude like Indiana's got
just like the different levels
yeah Gary but Gary is like a criminal
but he just like
smaller the tap for you to be the murder
capital of the country of a town that no
one's ever heard of like that do you
know how crazy that is like when we said
like Chicago and stuff and you're like
yeah obviously like New York City these
big cities and Gary just after a dude
after a Gary Indiana is like you know
just do it I know a Gary in his is I
mean it's a joke like they would see
yeah
the gear people forgive me can go to
Chicago and like I'm from Gary and like
Chicago has to just respect like they
have to show some respect
you know yeah I think you might be right
man I think we met after ah I'll go in
the end on this one cuz I think that's a
big upset that Minnesota we're gonna
think that the Lakes our rivers and
they're gonna get in one and enough to
try to go down and then have to get out
and drag your boat to the next Lake it's
just I don't but now say this is the
Mississippi River starts in Minnesota at
Lake Itasca National Park and I've
actually been there
it ends in Indiana and a lot of people
don't know that that's sure it's not
look that one up but it's uh but
definite Mississippi have that waterway
have that capability of moving things
from side to side you know in buddy Gary
a name is up against the they're against
like zyi or like Michigan no I think
it's like Gary Indiana like my it's very
close to Lake Michigan look Gary is
wherever the [ __ ] he wants to be okay
you tell Gary off sometimes he'll go
down a [ __ ] Bloomington you'll sleep
down there Gary I'll roll over to Andy
he does what he wants you would be
talking you you would be talking to Gary
before you Roz dude was Gary yeah you'd
like I thought your name was Ben and
he's like it's scary it's been Gary the
whole time and Ben is too late you're in
a corner you're to over you're done okay
so we'll roll with Indiana
next up all right the number one seed
Illinois verse the number nine seed
South Dakota South Dakota verse Illinois
Illinois they got me so I got a whole
say actually the only city in Illinois
is Chicago you should guess I got a lot
of guns there a lot of violence out
there look like just like a guy white
however
South Dakota brought us home to Brock
Lesnar
we got Brock Lesnar okay he probably
counts as at least 20 people and I'd
even bake as a few relatives that are
gorilla sized like him so if I got a
pick man I'm going with the SD South
Dakota boy
dang-son top vo coming here from Chicago
that mother I wanted to weigh in on
Illinois versus South Dakota please do
I'm saying Illinois is definitely gonna
win by a landslide
Illinois has a higher population well
South Dakota doesn't really have much it
just has Mount Rushmore
I mean Chicago by itself could easily
take down South Dakota we got a South
Side and we got hot dogs we could just
chase them around with hot dogs that we
have to that Wiener circle baby and I've
been over there and they called me the
n-word Wells trying to order a hot dog
but that's how they do it there it's
like that's all part of it it's like
part of their steek yeah it's like the
mustard thing it's that they don't use
it know you can only use must don't use
ketchup the same thing yeah weenies and
we use the n-word as well yeah bio
ketchup and then were fun man we're
mixing it up yeah I'll take it
it's just a [ __ ] yeah it's like a fun
place it's called wiener circles pretty
famous but this is I think look the guy
said it flat out Chicago alone could be
South Dakota I don't even think this is
the this is not even it's nothing but if
the head lands of South Dakota now that
is man that I know but they're too
spread out like it's you know it would
be did you ever hear like it was like
somewhere like Saipan or Center like
wherever one of the wars where did that
guy when the war ended and they didn't
tell him Paul Revere no no this was like
World War or the atomic bomb would drop
to the tongue bomb and you go to Saipan
like you know Japan like and today with
a fight on one of the islands this is
unreal I shouldn't be diving this far
into like I'm sure like I've no idea
this America we're talking about I know
but this so the point of it is this
there was a guy that was stuck in a hole
because he
no the war in tho yeah cuz they couldn't
get to him to tell them it is for phones
and later
so yeah about this guy said this dude
lived same birthday as me oh yeah after
the war ended
Oh nada spent 29 years or even we finish
that up knitting out in the Philippines
until his former commander traveled from
Japan to formally relieve him from duty
by order of the Emperor in 1974 he went
AWOL no no no they could they tell him
there's no day there was you know they
can't be like text him and be like hey
man like the war was like over like so
he just was like assumed he was on this
island and they were and they just
seemed that it was happening so he like
stayed and the kid and like made sure
you know just had no you know yeah I
mean look there's gotta be something
wrong with him a little bit okay I might
see that later dude man after 2 years
bro you gotta [ __ ] ask somebody if
people still but I think he was like by
himself you know but he doesn't want to
ask cuz he's afraid yes they were like
straight-up killing him are like you
know and so he can't go up to like
excuse me
is the war over and the guys like yeah
so and then they went through the trauma
of war who knows like what that you know
what going through the war could have
left him in a crazy mental state you
know and left him yeah they found him
like it was amusing 29 years it said
like 20 and yeah I mean I do agree
there's a point you know 15 years he's
like I if you talk to me is like I would
bet it's over yeah but there's still
something I say that's like maybe not
you know work I know also did you get to
Bill him for all that time served I hope
he does maybe that was he comes out and
get his check yeah and just like how
much did I give like thirty million
dollars like something insane like he's
like he got drafted so I think that's
what happened South Dakota you have too
many people that like Illinois to be on
their house before they realized that
like it even started yeah and like
they're I think they're too spread out
I've been in South Dakota I did a show
there and they had a parrot parrot in
the corner of the bar they put on the
bar yeah you've done that room and if
you said a profanity it would get them
upset yes and then they tell you so the
first show the parrots in their second
shows not a parrot and you're like where
they go we have a parrot room and you're
like so you there's another place this
parrot can go and not ruin the show yeah
that's in
it's insane to me and my audience for
that parrot was 10% I need yeah we
needed him he was his lorry Buster's
nailed up I think yeah there's a indoor
pool uh I don't think you stay there I
wouldn't do it if I had to go back man
it was hectic bro there why would they
not make I just never like I thought
there was nowhere for the parrot to go
yeah I didn't know they had a specific
room for it to go to they got room so
the parrot like had already seen your
hour and then he's like oh yeah the
parrot walked out yeah he unlocked
himself out of the cage no one's ever
seen that before it was he and he went
and he left the room and he just wasn't
like has I heard it he does a lot of
that the whole time you talk and you're
just like oh this guy's killing me yeah
but I just saw I love that there was a
room I love that there's a place for him
not to ruin the show and they they
choose for the early good show to get
ruined
I don't mind bringing a parrot out to
the Late Show I expect it yes it's a
Late Show yeah it's chaos oh I've seen a
guy with it and of a couple months ago
just like rolling just like it's nothing
just you know it's a piece bird man is
what it is but yeah I don't think Ellen
oi wins this round that's crazy we both
perform for that bird brothers dude dude
it's uh yeah it's crazy it's a good
beautiful animal all right let's move it
let's do one more bracket here yeah this
is great two for four more matchups for
me yeah I love this is wonderful man
it's been a real test of like I wish I
knew more about anything
I think I know more facts into some of
it that's good that you don't I think
it's gonna end up being five parts too
so it's really expansive it's really
more Joe Olivier
yeah all right number two seed Arizona
verse number seven seed New Mexico yo
what up the room look at his face I know
exactly where this guy's from where's
from Arizona Arizona yeah because he's
yeah he looks a he looks a little less
dreamcatcher II to me whose simple
reasons on why Arizona beats New Mexico
State any day of the week
any day of the year hook number one
we've got the Grand Canyon how you gonna
fight someone who lives in their natural
habitat in the Grand Canyon we just
leave them in and let them rot at the
bottom well you know how to work the
canyon they work the game number two
we've got copper for days yeah for days
you know how many pennies we can make
with copper them little Abraham
Lincoln's yeah how many we could drop
from the top of the Grand Canyon on
their heads like torture instant death
which was its war brother I mean Grand
Canyon and Penny's don't need a good
prison grin Kane is a great prison
I like that Grand Canyon down they
should have a prison huh how the hell is
grated of a [ __ ] prison
no observing together sheriff Joe Joe
just put them all down there the
prisoners yeah here's Numa here in New
Mexico we got a good bottle what's up
mr. Vaughn what's up Dean Cain I gotta
say if you undenied Dean underdog looks
like Dean King and truthfully I would
believe it's his brother yeah like if
he's was Dean Cain's brother yeah what's
that mr. Vaughn it's our brother I gotta
say Arizona and New Mexico I'm actually
from Tucson Arizona way and believe it
or not I don't think I don't think they
got it in him here's why first of all
all the Mexicans on the south side
they're heading back down to Mexico
this route is down all the rich white
people on the north side that's gonna be
like you said target practice and then
you got a bunch of what college kids in
the middle off a speedway racing cars
I'm from Arizona and I think New
Mexico's got this because they got
aliens
they've got UFC fighters and they've got
green chile which is gonna I think
really tear up some [ __ ] so
I'm from Arizona but I think that New
Mexico's got this all the way so I don't
know what are your thoughts and going
man I love that guy that guy did a
really great job I'll say this man
right back at you dude to be from one
and now live in the other that's
something you don't think about our
people gonna move so if you're in do you
go back and fight for your home state so
if we say this happens and then all
right like if you're sitting but like so
Arizona is littered with people not from
Arizona right so that state could empty
like if you're like New York Chicago all
these people that move on or they go
back home like you got like an Ohio and
I well they're like those people lived
there like that's where they're from
they're not you're not a town that's
like oh none of us are from here so they
could totally everybody from New
Mexico's from New Mexico no one's like I
moved to New Mexican population that was
born in another country are they gonna
go back to their home country so I think
you might have a lot of people if it's
in them if it's a war between states
that some people if they came here from
Mexico and they live in you know like
California Texas Arizona New Mexico yeah
they might be like [ __ ] it I'm out of
here
so I think you're gonna have a lot of
the population and that's a lot of your
working population there too like you're
sort of more labor jobs right I used to
work in countless restaurants in Tucson
Arizona all the back house of everybody
up there a lot of Latino workers a lot
of Mexican workers there right so think
I never bunch of rich white people don't
how to [ __ ] do anything right and
that could really really cost him you
know I think that's some of what this
young fellas saying no that yeah what
that's not in like yeah they're gonna go
home like I mean if you're fighting for
your state like so like if I don't live
I live in Tennessee now but if I if
we're fighting States and I lived it
here in California I would go home and
I'd fight for Tennessee so like once the
announcement goes out they're like hey
all the states are gonna fight I would
be I mean you could fight for Tennessee
how are you not living my glory dude if
they make the movie glory to glory - I
should get in it I does want my favorite
movies bro so it's so good i watch that
movie all the time I don't the HS is
still hold up huh
I haven't watched it a while I don't
believe in that war anymore
Silence of the Lambs I don't care
if we believe in her I mean [ __ ] you
know it happened there's nothing we you
and I can do about it we'd not do it no
no I was like I don't believe in that
entire war do glory to the comedy I've
just come in like it's a little more
lighthearted you me or anything into it
just us coming in how you doing hey guys
we want to talk to you about our proper
about we have to convince you to get
into it glory to glory - it's happening
I could see it why not you know we could
do it like we do this the glory t
Williams in it with us glory - is this
just the state's fighting okay who's it
gonna be then I think this guy did a
good job I mean Arizona you got the help
but I don't know man I think Arizona
people are gonna spread I think people
gonna go home I think there's oh I think
there's too many people that don't live
there so your population could be huge
but they're gonna go home people are
gonna go they don't they like they like
Phoenix and they like Arizona they wanna
fight for them no I think they're gonna
go like they're gonna feel safer because
they come from a Chicago in New York so
they're like I'm gonna go back to there
I'll live in you know in New Mexico's
Breaking Bad is out of New Mexico two
guys in a trailer cooking exactly a food
truck they [ __ ] ran off the day they
that's a made-up show but no one
questioned it no one's like all right
that ain't happening out there
everybody said yeah that's what happens
out there yeah but it doesn't go to
fight both of them wear their underpants
and a gas mask half the time everybody
the the brains of just like Walter
Walter why do they just think they both
dude ain't [ __ ] down there
how many people live in New Mexico I bet
it's less than six hundred it's a very
small population I just want to see how
I did a tour of the breaking bed thank
you you can do it privately you can do
it like it just shows up on your Google
Maps why don't you drive teach thing I
drove to the house and the ladies was
sitting out there yeah they're getting
really pissed cuz people are actually
throwing pizzas on the roof because it
was a scene from Breaking Bad yeah did
you see anything I saw her sitting in
the yard and I was too nervous to pull
up in front cuz you know she knows right
that you know what's happening what's up
with this population here Nicholas
two million in New Mexico and how many
Arizona
seven seven million so I mean let's say
it that goes down to four I think three
million go back to where they okay let's
say so three many people leave because
you also have a lot of people in the
North who are down there just snow bunny
but that's gonna kind of be everywhere
you also have a lot of sex not like
Arizona dude there's a female Ike
Phoenix is straight up known as no one's
from there I went I was there and golfed
recently and golf to these guys they're
all from Canada so those guys are gonna
wipe your hands that's five guys that
won't be there so I think you're gonna
have a lot of corrected numbers please
five guys will be back New Mexico I'll
ride with you I'll ride with you on the
upset New Mexico it'll be then you guys
could go to New Mexico I think it might
have some I think New Mexico also will
have like some old-school kind of like
Western kind of Mountain voodoo going on
you know yeah some of that as techie and
sort of maybe American voodoo if Arizona
does have like I've watched a lot of
cartel stuff recently and if they have
if Arizona gets seen those people to
stay though like those core tell people
to get out it's real it's the real dude
but deal but I don't think they're going
to and I think New Mexico has those
cartel people to its new yeah it's new
it's the newer of the Mexico so then now
that's another point you might have a
lot of Mexicans Mexican people that
would go from Arizona back well I'm just
gonna fight for New Mexico's because if
we're gonna be a state yes then I'm
gonna be the state that I want to be I'm
gonna be a state does at least call New
Mexico because the [ __ ] Hansons
jerseys are gonna be nobody I think
you're gonna have yet so that's quite a
flag of the Mexico flag oh yeah Ana's
bring it up it's put nueva in the front
yeah nuevo all right well we got a
couple upsets in this round next matchup
number three Washington State verse
number six Utah Washington versus Utah
I'm just gonna say Washington wins
we got the funds from companies like
Amazon Boeing Microsoft we have the
smart people that run those companies
all Utah has is Salt Lake Washington
wins gang gang gang brother Wow
yeah what else is okay here's Utah
what's up Theo I'm just get these
matchups we got here we got Utah and
Washington State now I live in Utah
originally from Georgia and down on the
south you know but you know what they
call Utah the color Utah the Texas of
the West I don't know if anybody calls
it there but I do we got a lot of guns
here a lot of conservative folks so you
know what that means we had a war with
Washington and we would smack those
liberal [ __ ] looks like I was the
Truman's oh yeah I could feel that I
could feel that guy coming to my car hey
registration please yeah absolutely
one thing I've learned from all these
videos is every state thinks they have
the most guns yeah that's true
everybody's guns apparently there's a
lot of guns out there yeah one guy had
like 30 guns in his rooms like we got
the guns I already showed okay yeah he's
got the guns guns that's a good point
though - yeah it's a war but you can
find unique ways to win it now you are
gonna have a lot of smart people over
there in Washington
I don't know if those smart people are
gonna [ __ ] fight like I'm talking
about what we're talking about so look
at like Salt Lake so you got Mormons so
like they're they already feel like
outcast they're already like they have
like a very easy outlet to each other to
like meat right so like they could
straight up it's a silver war they're
already meeting
they're already meeting it's always so
already you have most of that state
knows what to do out the gate so like
they're they're probably a month they're
like once you start to hear the
rumblings of the war happening they've
already met yes there was that easy for
them to get together and like it so
there are there a month ahead and like
thing but I like that he said the money
they talk about Washington like like I
don't think Seattle's will bring
anything to the table as far as like
fighting but the money that they
straight-up can bring in like the the
people that live it that's pretty wild
when they're in there your back is
against the water water no one can hit
you from Canada's above you so they're
not going to do anything and you're cool
with Canada you can maybe like you know
loop around like yeah maybe I'm gonna
fit like because they
because they're very liberal like you
know it's like they're very they're very
good talkers they're like you know
yes smooth talkers but you could have no
that's Oregon I said like it was an
auntie fad like at the very protest II
we're like oh yes you can get a lot of
people that could be protesting they're
not gonna fight no and then so it could
be a large group that just like we don't
stand for this and then they just get
murdered in melee yeah go fight it feels
like a cell phone out in somebody's
video and over ii ii got real yeah this
is gonna be a real deal this is a real
deal so like this is a straight-up
yeah these are people i mean again you
we can find unique ways that what would
make people win I mean it is fascinating
the amount of brain power and stuff
you're gonna have at some of those huge
tech companies and stuff like that so
what are they gonna be able to access
they're gonna be able to like have
access to more drones to unique ways
it'll win hack into your right I think
I'm gonna hack into Utah but I don't get
the Utah gives a [ __ ] dude the Mormons
aren't like they're not a bunch of
internet junkies I mean they're out
there they're all at a meeting right now
they're meeting constantly 24 hours a
day there are gue guai like where's like
in or like internet is like is that like
Washington like Google's California yeah
so what if they shut down that they're
like if someone shuts down the internet
like so you're straight these that could
have they're like we only give ourself
Internet right so I guess if they I
gotta now the internet works but like in
a unike ssin would be is a button that
they can be like no more internet and
then like all these other states
communication is over dude how big are
these states
Utah's enormous and you got to get all
these people gotta get together now I
like that there it is like I think the
Mormons like I think they probably have
like different systems I think they're
prepared for mountain internets to go
out right and so they like have like
signals and stuff like that Hawks Hawks
go up in the air
you want to talk about brain power Utah
has Ken Jennings who won 73 straight
games of Jeopardy
so and they got money yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's very very smart
he was just know he knows a lot of facts
though like but that could be good you
would never want his opinion on like
what to do but you would be like we're
fighting washington dude like how many
mcdonald's are they have and he like
knows like he tells you all these stuff
and you're like that's uh that's why
this guy's good like how much water can
a dolphin drink yeah day and you know
and he's like any it tells you and then
you're like all right all right yeah the
war might stop because the other team
just wants to meet him yeah
they seen him outburst as now you're
gonna have now Seattle has some soft
dudes up there man you know I don't
think I was gonna bring that home was
gonna bring the heat Spokane's gonna
bring oh yes okay everybody's rooting
for this tab ya lousy uh Bellevue it's
right up against Idaho like I was just
in if they call was like they just had a
guy didn't some guy just get ya in
Tacoma Spokane no yeah they oh I watched
it on Netflix as the thing with a
terrorist stuff almost happens and they
catch a guy and the guy was in Tacoma
Spokane and he had it he was about to it
was about to go down and they caught him
like at the last minute yeah I really
like Kalin's point that he brought up
about the Tongan population in Utah was
the largest in the States besides Hawaii
the what the Tongan population a very
Samoans yeah they're like Samoan people
they're huge yeah they can fight the
round where they it there's in Utah only
huge time there's a military bases off
the coast of Washington as well over
there like and this is a tough one what
do you guys think here's the big think
of borders like so when they're fighting
Utah's gonna worry about everywhere
watching doesn't you know a people we
can throw it when you don't worry about
the ocean how many people you can throw
to yeah and you don't throw at the top
of each other's the mountains though you
taught us so much I know but you have
every but you got every state's around
yeah so you're surrounded so like you
have to spread people out and they're
already under populated we can go to the
fans unless you want to let's do it okay
with you Nate yeah you have all those
people you know 5050 with 14,000 votes
that's what I uh that swings me I mean
that's crazy brother means seven that
hasn't votes a face dude how many be
fourteen thousand votes and it's 50/50
first of all thank you to everybody that
voted that's fascinating dude I've noted
some in my life 14,000 times dude we
don't require ID so yeah okay ticket
what's the popular
what did we do we do that I like you I
mean Washington seven and a half and
Utah is 3.1 that's a big difference too
and and then Washington's got like some
pride like some south pride like you
know the South is proud to be where
they're from Tacoma Spokane like that
Washington Eastern working crowd to be
yeah Utah's like the Mormons they might
just be like yeah let's just go find
another place to be you know we don't
even where I'm in fight we're just more
worried about our faith and moving
forward that way they yeah they could
almost not relate to Utah and they blend
right into Canada yeah yeah so I think I
could see I've got money I like that
money up there like you said but now the
Mormon Church has so much money an
insane amount of money right yeah
everybody with their words like his
Mormon just in Utah like where they're
like it's like 90% it's not somewhere
else like like like Catholics like you
know it's so big of a thing that they
could get so much help like they're you
know they've got numbers they got phone
numbers of people they can call it
you're like you don't even know yeah I
need a cares like a secret world but if
if the Mormons are basically trapped
they can't outside call there's not a
Utah's of the most where the Mormons are
at yeah so that can be all in state
calling that's where the Pope lives of
Mormons yeah yeah so that's their their
jaw mortar I think his name is John
Morgan so what you go Washington
it's such a tough call man I mean the
people said 5050
that's not the least population
Utah's 3 million less people but they're
in the voting poll that many people did
they kept it tight take care things like
that's that shows there Washington with
how many there's 4 million more on the
internet and it was a freaking
electronic vote 4 million more people in
Utah
straight up came out they secretly came
out that's you Washington should be like
it should have been 70/30 just cuz Utah
smaller yep and just because they know
how to work internet better people are
sometimes people are using gold people
communicating with goldfish ain't
getting up too many people against the
war and Utah's like yeah up like he says
again will do or do it yeah and we'll
all have lunch here we don't have any
coffee and they do it all on no coffee
no coffee
whereas as Seattle's up there star
bucking too much corporate culture I
think to in in Washington where you're
gonna get a lot of people that are just
if the Starbucks is closed or something
for a day they're gonna [ __ ] saw
their own arms off you know whereas in
our you me people that leak up to Canada
because you're right there to me but
like I don't even want to got here I'm
out of here
dragging talk can't get out yeah just
point me in the direction with the
emails there works
wow that's which I thought we were going
to Washington in one point yeah that was
that was a best were the tournament all
right but I mean that just shows you how
close it is to yeah and I think maybe
even we'd have to land on something yeah
alright next matchup number four
Colorado versus the lowest seed
remaining in the tournament Montana III
can't tell how much I love this I love
that this is you're doing this I think
it's a great sport I've seen em oh thank
you that's some podcast like to bring
people together we like to divide it's
such a good idea to think about like who
would you know straight-up civil war
between Stan out it's so because before
everybody thought I'm rooting for this
and real life to happen so I love just
to see I think we're getting the wheels
turning and yeah I think we're one step
closer to how crazy if in two years they
started using this as a reference yeah
for a real war that and then they do it
and then we have to go speak for our
state's and what if our brackets still
good like
let's go feel Vaughn here on you have
experience in this you talked about this
once on your podcast and then so did you
ever think this would come true uh yeah
actually uh you can either here be in a
party talking about it right we dive
into it real fast
I've got about eight hours on the
subject that's true next seen it all bro
alright here's uh a deal
is James here from Colorado one away and
on the March Madness state wars against
Montana and Colorado thanks James come
on man it's not even a fight okay case
for Colorado a United States Air Force
Academy teach all those cadets to drop
bombs on some Montana ass beat we got
NORAD some special [ __ ] with some GPS
don't know what it does but it's pretty
badass and see what there's seven people
in Montana
bro the millions of potheads in Colorado
could take them on so easy
Montana's ass bro they got bears and
[ __ ] that's all but gang gang buzzbuzz
later gang brah I love but one thing I
love I feel is that he said a b c and
that was one two three yeah that's
pretty cool and i love that that's code
and that's a code that we use sometimes
here um that's a good point yeah i know
i mean i mean that air for that's huge
it is they're the only thing I'll savor
the air force those are people that are
on board with our country that will be
on board of their state and we'll go
home and fight for this state the way
they will fight for the country is the
way they would fight for the state
they're not gonna stay and just be like
well then I just do Colorado they're
very proud to be where they're from and
I mean that's straight-up like how many
of those people are from Colorado and
though it's almost a hundred percent if
they're not they're leaving right and
they're gonna go fight at home so that's
gone look I can have their jet so that's
a thing of the Jets are probably gonna
stay there so they will still have
access to to Jen's the facility they
have the deficit is I didn't recruited
someone who can apply a nice facilities
but there will have to be enough people
from Colorado that cannot apply they
would have enough they that could you
know that could put it together and do
it well I already like Colorado in this
yeah but I mean like yeah Montana's
cherries cherry blooms they always have
a team that gets beaten early in a
Little League World Series
they they have Dodge City which it has a
large federal prison they're gonna make
you come into them
I think Montana would just say hey come
on itis no no you're gonna have to go
get them and then you know now you're on
their territory like we're some of these
states that are bigger I think we'll
we'll just straight up like gang gang
it's gonna meet at the border Montana
you're gonna get to him like are they
already lost their fight and you're not
good they're hiding dude like they're
gonna make you like yeah we're gonna
have to go look around for them but yeah
I think you only to look for a little
while and then you'll find him what if
they I don't know what their mouth they
have good Mountains yeah they've got a
very vast terrain on the east side
Estates very flat like they would need
that's their advantage to use their
terrain let's hear what he says you know
call them here hey Theo just weighing in
on the Montana versus Colorado state war
yes sir
and and to be honest there's there's too
many reasons that we would win this one
so I'm just gonna list off just a few
just a few I could go on for probably I
could probably start a podcast or why
Montana would beat Colorado but we're
just gonna list off a few all right guys
that's a lot of episodes fourth biggest
state you can't even find people in
Montana you come in trying to try to
take our women trying to take our towns
for your for Colorado zone nah ain't
gonna happen you're gonna you're gonna
find more cows and human stock number
two more cows and humans dog we are me
we got so much meat to feed our army you
can't win a war on bread and rice and
and little little Keebler Elf cookies
you can't do that dog can't do that and
that's all them stoners in Colorado
Orion man you know them stoners in
Colorado or just eating Luke little
little Samoas Girl Scout cookies selling
telluride yeah can't win a war on that
know everybody's got a gun in Montana
that's what who's gonna come in and beat
that who anyway I love you see Oh a gang
gang baby
baby keep doing you you to pop I love
him I love how he got black or two as it
went along so that shows you the
transformative abilities of the menthe a
nice he's the black people of Montana
there they go I know black any
introduced yeah and you're like you know
what that's pretty convincing that the
weed may have really defeated the libido
of Colorado of like they're not what
their populations gotta be wildly
different though that's you know he did
type of you ain't gonna find them I tell
you Montana's gonna sucker you in it's
gonna be via the with Mel Gibson that
movie that he was in yes where they make
them go yeah they're gonna sucker you in
you're gonna make you go come get us
yeah like aa little girl running or
something you're like what's going and
you go and then they just boom bombard
you're gonna walk into your own death in
my face come get us man yeah and there's
a lot of like dudes like to wear shorts
and be on bicycles and Denver and stuff
like that and the great people but I
don't know if there weren't gonna want
to go fight really I don't know though
but you got the mountains in Colorado
you got people this ski I mean I just
think you have to mixed it's a big state
man
I think Montana has everything that
Colorado has accepts the turning soft
like Boulder is basically another
Seattle they're getting very they're
getting soft out there Montana is
alchemy that's what Joe Rogan feeds off
of I liked his meat argument the meat
argument yeah you're gonna feed your
people but I'm sure this is it four
million different it's yeah it's a 1
million for Montana and five and a half
for cars like for there to be I mean a
the population alone like III agree with
some of these big populations like where
we had you know yeah what do we have we
ought open this yes it's pretty much a
straight up just because of that do many
people there to new people and I can go
seek 401 you're gonna lose eventually
you know even if you got a [ __ ] you
know book I had enough people like it
like being Ohio I would still had
millions of people you'd barely have a
million in Montana I have they got it I
mean yes you want anything Nick and they
and they they they lost it all when they
got out of that first round like that
was there that's a good point yeah
they lost probably too many
people they were named I've ordered a
second round if you'd like you get that
second round after that first round and
their populations 600,000 midst down
half's gone
I just lost quite a bit of money I had
Montana going a long way in this thing
but damn who the [ __ ] you been I love
how you probably alright last matchup of
the day are we sure about that one what
did the people say people said 65% said
Colorado that's a lot of montanans the
montana is showing up like they're there
they're proud yeah they definitely proud
there's no doubt I just think you got
out the first round dude that's great
that's great you guys did it and what
you should be doing stead of fighting
karo trying to like get into Colorado
like you should be like hey look we took
out these other two y'all should be
rethinking stuff and merging Colorado
merging and then come up cuz I mean look
you got something coming next that's
gonna be no I'll say this then I think
you might have some of that we could
start a state now called Montana righto
and they could advance if we want I like
it month Montana righto call it Tana oh
yeah I'll call a tonic and ooh call
Wattana sounds good because I think you
could have that I think you could have I
think Montana's is that throwing chance
I think they're gonna lose so many
people in that first round and it's
unreal that they made out what they're
still there's one final making out that
first should be half that's what
somebody goes to Colorado do we show me
that's what they the speech they give
him money we should be proud that we
made it out here but we cannot be
Colorado chin right now we've lost too
many people that's going for it involved
with them Calla Tana Carl tanner Wow Wow
and that's how it happens bro that's how
it happens in real life too yeah out the
gate like that's crazy one more battery
Montana last matchup of the second round
the number one seed California number
one overall seed
two with a population of 40 million
first the eight seed Alaska through what
if someone's just gonna just see this in
the c-collar Taylor like their thoughts
to be like what like they don't like it
they just see it
where they here why we didn't looking
they're just like what what's happening
I think it's pretty obvious skeleton
all right California and Alaska Sea
doodle ask I'll say this has some of it
probably the most fierce resilient
people let's see if we had a video
submission here this is officer from
where California man California
California takes number one all the way
we have two Joe Rogan's the jaw goes I
don't know about David Goggin gloves in
the court that's all we need that guy
what did the guy just literally he looks
like you to be an assassin and like he
just got done we have a lot of assassins
that listen that's great you have a good
assassin population oh yeah have you
seen everybody calling about the gun our
let's hear the rebuttal from Alaska oh
it's up Theo Nate this is West out here
in California and I just wanted to give
my personal comment on the war between
California Alaska and uh gotta say I
think Alaska takes his hands down I mean
I've lived in six other states before I
moved out here to California and the
people out here in California man
especially on the west coast on the
coast pretty weak pretty weak I agree so
I think Alaska you know if they take all
those uh those fishing boats you know
that they use out and like whatever
ocean out there you know Deadliest Catch
whatever get those guys come down on the
ships rolling the san francisco take
over San Francisco the Bay Area use that
as like a Forward Operating Base and
just move on from there you know I think
they'll have no problem you know they
already got those you know 50 Cal
military-grade sniper rifles that they
used to hunt down you know mooses and
grizzly bears Mike's their calls so I
think it's no problem I might run an
issue when you get to like Stockton
you know Fresno Bakersfield because you
know the people out there a little bit
you know a little bit more gritty but
Diaz brothers
I think Alaska you know I hate to say
you know cuz now I live in California
but I think Alaska's got this hands down
alright his brothers are two guys that
will go to
if they fight people because their
that's a bit like their a weapon they're
so good at fighting yet and they still
one of them sleeps in a holster that's
what I heard someone taught someone told
me once a Nick Diaz got it in a fight he
was right his motorcycle
got into a fight with another kind of
car our motorcycle they pull over
they then both start fighting that guy
stabbed Nick Diaz with the leg with a
pin like a your writing pen and then he
Diaz respect him so much they became
training partners I was told that I
don't know if that's true or not but I
hope it is and like that's why I'm
someone that's coming from so could
Alaska beat Stockton I think is what
we're at now they how many they're
powered because with the population it's
got to be seven hundred seventy thousand
that's seven hundred seventy thousand in
Alaska dude did like that's verse forty
million its yeah I mean it's it's like
anybody you can have I think it Alaska
be annoying for California like you'll
be pesky
yeah like but it's like straight up they
could just sin like Stockton and like
Dawkins in the Stockton's 320,000 alone
320,000 and I don't know if 300,000 from
Stockton would beat sound I don't know
they wouldn't last me you go boo man and
I'll ask a frozen men they're not gonna
feel the first 20 punches because
they're frozen and some of them are guys
that have fought bears probably like you
know like in their life have been like
if you're fought a bear like you would
be able to walk you'd be able to find
someone that's fought a bear a lot
quicker than you should
right in Alaska but also they'll have
the Trojan bear trick where they all
hide in a bear and they have it come
down and Cal Berkeley and be like oh we
got a new mascot and they pop out of Cal
Berkeley they would destroy yeah most of
the University of what UCLA dude I could
[ __ ] I could eat I could beat
everybody's ass UCLA dude and I've only
been not only worked out twice this year
and not everybody but probably they'll
60% of the people over there a good
amount of people like I would walk with
my head high and I yell at campus what
do people say people say it's gonna be
wildly California whoa that is a 2% said
California 48 person is
people hate California yeah anyway
California and then Alaska is very proud
and they're gonna you know they're it'll
take a lot to kill them but it there's
just not enough people man like they
they they're gonna fight hard yeah then
be no wives pretty wild they made it out
think of milk water though and get it to
flow down oh and like to drown
California well they could come in like
I think it's gonna be surprised I think
California is gonna feel Alaska but
you're not gonna beat Alaska but you're
definitely gonna be like why did that
take as long it shouldn't take as long
it's gonna take us six years California
should have just they like I mean like
they should have just moved on and yeah
it should have been very quick and
they're gonna be like I'll give you the
town we'll get knocked out and you'd be
like khadi that was like they they will
regret that as California precedes I'll
say they got yeah they got right out a
little bit
they will beat San Francisco I'll say
that Alaska will beat San Francisco but
they gotta Oakland like over the water
now they got Oakland I pray you get into
Hayward those hard heads and [ __ ] like
that they're not gonna build right over
the water right so right but there will
at least be San Francisco and people
will cheer them as they beat San
Francisco yeah
80% of California will cheer for Alaska
as they pummel San Francisco and
probably as they pummel a lot of
Hollywood specifically but then the rest
of the area is gonna kick on Alaska will
think they're doing good and that's
because California is letting them like
they're gonna let them they're gonna
lead them into like well go to Hollywood
you can go to San Francisco that like
they're gonna be like we even want to
get rid of his deadweight anyway so like
they let him come in and fight in Alaska
gonna like dude we're about to win this
which is I think is seen in glory I
think it once seen in glory he's like
thanks sometimes he's like we did it and
then it's just isn't that the very end
of the movie it's like and then it's a
whole other thing and he's like he's
like it's in that's what Alaska's gonna
feel ass it's gonna be like dude we made
it dent and right before I go down there
like we get we're at like it's proud to
be up for a blast I love you brother
like it's like one of they say that and
then it's like a wrap and it's in my
last thing very poetic and I think
that's true I think is exactly the way
they're gonna read
really cause some help but that it's
gonna end like that in California we'll
move on
Wow that does it we're down to our sweet
savage 16 Jaipur gasps I got a new
special I want to get I want to keep up
to date with this California call a ton
I'm an out TV that's uh that's insane a
new state with big baby Glen Davis is
supposed to come in and uh best ball
player you know yeah yeah I know you're
supposed to come in but it looks like
he's getting he's he's filming something
outside of town he said he could also
just be hi but it might be Caleb Presley
and then Nick Swardson for the
championship oh wow that'd be great
mm I love it but Nate man yeah you guys
check out Nate special I haven't seen it
yet
but it's nice that I watched cheers yeah
I haven't flown blessed you flew last
actually that is true Jim Gaffigan not
not Nick Swardson for the championship
Oh Gaskins be Gavin gonna be terrific on
this yeah we're intrigued man we retreat
but today you were terrific man and I'm
glad you came in and congratulations on
your success dude big fan of YouTube
buddy well a huge huge fan
what's nice you say there's not a lot of
southern guys that are that are in
comedy and it's us you know now we're
gonna stick together just like normal
just like this just like these states
have sticking you know where the mana
yeah Louisiana senousy look we can't
pronounce it but but we're good
Thank You Nate
[Music]
I'll share this piece of thought it's
gonna take
little time for me to set that parking
brake
Oh
[Music]